in the summer of 1965 then 25 year old
betsy cohen was wrapping up an
internship at a prestigious law firm and
entering her final year at the
university of pennsylvania law school
as a top student one would expect her to
be offered a full-time position but
cohen says a senior partner at the firm
was not ready to offer a woman a job to
which she responded i think it's your
loss
indeed it was
after clerking for a federal appellate
judge and starting her own law firm
cohen founded a bank in 1974 ran it for
a quarter century then sold it for over
330 million dollars
then she started another bank the
bancorp which focused on providing white
label banking and payment services to
non-bank companies like paypal and ran
that until the end of 2014.
in recent years cohen has emerged as a
prolific deal maker in the world of
special purpose acquisition companies or
better known as spax she was early to
the reverse merger craze closing her
first deal in march of 2016.
since then cohen and partners which
include her son daniel have raised over
4.2 billion dollars across 13 spac
listings with six mergers completed to
date
according to data provider spac research
only two other firms have completed more
reverse mergers than cohen and her
partners
cohen's independent thinking has netted
her a fortune that forbes estimates is
at 230 million dollars
in addition to investing cohen also
serves on a number of boards
including the brookings institute and
the metropolitan opera
she has also wielded a subtler influence
on wall street by mentoring women who
are now excelling at the highest levels
of business and financial services
you